[Music]
my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here my tiny corner of nowhere
there's nowhere left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
[Music]
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do but they stay because
of all the things they can be can you
feel this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday hello if you're watching this
I'm dead
I created a hidden object an easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this parcel and how the hell is
he winning find him
I'm talking about two life-and-death
stuff the Oasis the world's most
important economic resource
there's nothing less than a war for
control of the future
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
I only came here to escape
[Music]
but I found something much bigger than
just myself
are you willing to fight
helped us save the oasis
[Music]
you